i really want to make a statement and
just show it in the videos like it
doesn't really matter where you came
from as long as you really
want it bad enough you'll do whatever it
takes to get it i want to show my son
that anything that you believe
that you can do you can do it my why is
from my father i've seen him work for so
many
years i want to give him some free time
i'm going to do it for
my family back home i was working the
call center for five years
and it's just not it wasn't for me that
we recently made
under enjoying lockdown and found that
property was
almost my way out so it was a blessing
in disguise money
equaled happiness to me and the more
that i grow and the more that i evolved
i realized money doesn't actually equal
happiness it really doesn't
what equals stop wasting happiness is to
me then get on the phone
oh my god i'm stressed on their behalf
no relax the roof to get away from
everybody
not even one of them can close the door
ten contestants
five challenges but just one shot to
financial
freedom i'm the underdog your mind
you're evicted
can i have a big mac and a carpet
shutter face